ja das könnte
die größte aktion dieser art in
deutschland glaube ich bisher gegeben
hat damen und herren wir können auch
noch mehr wenn es schwerere von helios
und ist es klar dass das kind mit der
kriminalität auf
[Musik]
das ist nicht mehr kleinkram das muss
viel mehr passieren
das sind keine kleinkriminellen der
kampf gegen die organisierte
kriminalität wird eine daueraufgabe sein
[Musik]
denken sie warum die polizei ermittelt
bereinigt
wir gehen jetzt intensiv an das schreckt
aber nicht ab weiter die geschäfte zu
machen
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt an die herren an dem
punkt wo wir sind waren das über
jahrzehnte lang keine
integrationspolitik gegeben hat das
problem ist so groß geworden auch die
öffentliche aufmerksamkeit ist so groß
geworden dass wir jetzt das große
besteck herausholen müssen da müssen die
gesetze verschärft werden und es müssen
ganz knallhart der regel umgesetzt
werden das ist nicht nur nadelstiche
sind die stören sondern dass sie
tatsächlich beeindrucken und verhalten
verändern eine große block sind die
razzien die japaner mal in großem stile
stattfinden aber auch manchmal jede
woche im kleinen stattfinden für die
unterschiedlichen staatlichen
institutionen dafür sorgen dass die
regeln eingehalten werden dass sich
jeder an recht und gesetz hält
davor hat so ja
wir haben seit mitte der achtzigerjahre
diese kleinen entwicklung gehen die
nordrhein westfalen von 108 deutsche
familien aus die dividendentitel ziert
haben wir haben rund 14.000 straftaten
die diesen clans zugeordnet werden und
da können davon 6000 tatverdächtigen
reden die wir bisher ermittelt haben
wir haben 26 tötungs liegt in zwei davon
sogar erfolgreich das ist nicht mehr
kleinkram das sind keine kleinen
kriminellen sondern das ist
kleinkriminalität
die altistin er im zusammenhang mit der
bekämpfung der kriminalität handelt sich
um eine shisha bar ist natürlich wichtig
und zu gucken wer ist da werd ich da auf
und man jetzt mit dem da auch weil die
strukturen dieser libanesischen
großfamilien doch sehr undurchsichtig
uns noch sind
[Musik]
auch bringen
shisha bar sind nach unseren
erkenntnissen sich alle aber die die wir
wirklich im fokus haben gewinnen
brennpunkt haben wo sie verabredet
wieder zu straftaten im bereich btm das
betäubungsmittelgesetz wir haben
festgestellt dass es mit menschen die
dort arbeiten bzw der frage
schwarzarbeit bis hin zum sozialen zu
mittwoch die größte aktion dieser art in
deutschland glaube ich finde die es je
gegeben hat
das ist jetzt einfach mal zu
demonstrieren um auch im gegenüber der
polizei anzuzeigen
damen und herren wir können auch noch
mehr in berlin ist es schon die stimme
als sie noch klein westfalen und so zu
stelle möchte ich hier nicht haben
ich habe mit einigen clans gesprochen
wie jetzt eigentlich die grazien so
ankommen ob das abschreckt wir haben
gesagt natürlich ist das belastend
irgendwo ich glaube was da am meisten
weh tut ist dass wir häufig da sind das
ist nervt wir gehen jetzt intensiv an
und wir unterstützen die polizei und
justizbehörden dabei und man muss eben
vorsichtiger arbeiten das schreckt aber
nicht ab weiter die geschäfte zu machen
[Musik]
warum die polizei mit
klostermann
[Musik]
die frage wo tut es weh sich ebenfalls
sehr schön fokussiert auf einen bereich
wenn du jetzt du da wir mal ans geld
geht das heißt die verstecken jetzt
bisschen besser ihre einkünfte würden
sondern geldspielgeräte unseren
automaten mag man kaum glauben da sind
in der regel oftmals mindestens
fünfstelligen geldbeträge drin und wir
tragen hier eingeschlossen worden sind
und dann gar keine steuern bezahlt
worden sind dann tut das schon weh oder
wenn das ding abgelaufen und dann kann
man die ganze kohle einbehalten und das
macht dann schon unterschichten
plötzlich da ich mal 20.000 euro in der
kasse fehlen mit dem man kalkuliert hat
das reicht aber bei weitem sich aus
diese razzien es muss viel mehr
passieren dass die auch richtig angst
bekommen und das klappt nur mit harten
regeln
[Musik]
ich bin selbständig und doch nur mein
kollege lausitz ist da doch mal
vor 1
unbereinigt
anfangs haben sie dabei
rotterdam musste
der z3 wissen gar nicht genau
doch genau wissen fürs dabei oder
ich kann ihnen eine richtung ausrichten
haben seit unserem war dabei ich finde
das wäre auch bahrain haben zu samstag
zu haben braucht ausstellung mit 12.000
auch einfach so dabei
respekt und angst haben die natürlich
die klaren sforza beweislastumkehr
das ist natürlich fantastisches mittel
das die beweisen müssen und das ganze
geld her wir zeigen den handelnden
personen frühzeitig auf dass sie sich
nicht außerhalb der regeln ungestraft
außerhalb der regeln dieser gesellschaft
bewegen können das heißt frühzeitiges
eingreifen bei verkehrsverstößen
frühzeitiges eingreifen in den
gewerbebetrieben also auf zeigen es gibt
regeln und die regeln sind einzuhalten
wir nehmen diese verstöße nicht hin
[Musik]
grundsätzlich ist die frage der
klangqualität nicht nur ein problem also
nordrhein-westfalen speziell in essen da
es gibt einige ortsbus dazugehört berlin
da geht's um bremen teilweise in
niedersachsen
bei einsätzen von den clans ist
bestücken hübschen aber auch körperliche
gewalt schlagen und wir haben ja
durchaus fehler gehabt in dem nach
erfolgter maßnahme mitarbeitern
mitarbeitern zusammengetreten worden
sind in unseren brennpunkt in unseren
hotspots war es ausgesprochen schwierig
kleinste maßnahmen an einen schon
durchzusetzen
spektakulärer schlag gegen die
organisierte kriminalität in deutschland
in einer streng geheimen operation wurde
clan-chef ibrahimi in seiner wohnung in
bremen festgenommen und anschließend in
seiner heimat libanon ausgeflogen für
mich ist die abschiebung von herrn idee
ein ganz ganz starkes signal an diese
organisierte kriminalität damit wird
klar dass die behörden übergreifende
abstimmung funktioniert das auch nichts
nach außen dringt im vorfeld die sich
nicht vorbereiten können
und es ist ein schwerer schlag für diese
strukturen was auch gut so ist
[Musik]
das ist eigentlich sonst
ich gehe davon aus dass er über kurz
oder lang auch wieder in deutschland
auftaucht und das ist natürlich die
einreisebehörden am zuge den zu erkennen
um dann ein reise auch zu verhindern und
wenn er es doch irgendwie schaffen
sollte ihn möglichst schnell wieder aus
deutschland aus zu befördern
wir haben hier den innenstadtbereich
abgebildet mit den einzelnen punkten der
farbe das sind die legte die den letzten
tagen festgestellt haben dass wir auf
dieser karte dokumentiert und ist
natürlich rein visuell eigentlich schon
relativ einfach zu erkennen wo die
schwerpunkte setzen und wohne
problembereiche haben entscheidend ist
für uns das haben wir auch gesagt in der
form von nadelstichen dass wir pro woche
zwischen einen vier einsätze fahren das
heißt wie szene ist ständig beunruhigt
tages kann es nur ganz kleine
durchsuchungsmaßnahmen sein
ein bisschen natürlich auch dann zu ganz
großen einsetzen wo wir mehrere hundert
beamte ihn beamte eingesetzt
[Musik]
wir haben viele ordnungswidrigkeiten
user verhalten man muss natürlich auch
zeigen dass geld verdient in der regel
immer fahrzeuge oberhalb 400.000 euro
marke
das feld ist riesengroß ich glaube in
einer gesamtsumme der verschiedenen
maßnahmen das ist ein wichtiger baustein
und wie ich finde verdeutlicht auch
gegenüber den menschen und gegenüber den
bürgern dass es keine rechtsfreien räume
gibt
[Musik]
fast die kriminalitätsprävention
betrifft haben natürlich nur sinn wenn
es auch mit anderen maßnahmen flankiert
wird nimmt die clans die kinder weg ist
etwas plakativ aber trotzdem ein thema
was man diskutieren muss wir haben
kriminalität an unseren schulen es gibt
immer wieder vorfälle körperverletzungen
beleidigungen ich sag mal das klassische
abziehen von handys jacke und schuhe
wenn es schwerwiegende familie ist dann
ist das klar dass das kind mit der
kriminalität aufwächst das sind kinder
die müssen zur schule gehen die müssen
gebildet werden die mussten weg in die
gesellschaft eröffnet werden und dann da
ist es wohl stoppen nach name crew oder
rambo oder lieschen müller ist da
unterstützen wir sie auch über
sozialarbeit über elternarbeit und und
und
[Musik]
berlin kann den kampf gegen deutschland
kann den kampf auch nrw den kampf gegen
die organisierte kriminalität mit diesem
nadelstichen absolutes der bilder in
allen ländern wo es mafia strukturen
gibt es organisierte kriminalität gibt
dann ist sie auch nicht weg sondern sie
ist immer da wir hatten vor 2015 schon
erhebliche probleme mit der
organisierten kriminalität der kampf war
so gut wie verloren 2015 mit der
flüchtlingswelle ist das ganze ja noch
bevor es hier wollen und wenn sie mich
fragen ob wir heute nur die spitze des
eisbergs bekämpfen dann antworte ich
ihnen das mag vielleicht seien aber
irgendwo muss nun beginnen der kampf
gegen die organisierte kriminalität wird
eine daueraufgabe sein
wir wären richtige ghettos bekommen und
er wird uns immer jahrzehntelang noch
begleiten was wird kein weg daran vorbei
an schulen sagen wir die lehrer wenn ich
hier die kids frage was wollen sie
später werden dann bis antwort rapper
wird deutsche rapper akon wurden hier
rumstehen und erst wenn die komplett
ausgebaut werden und eine scheiß
erzählen weiß ich war damals erschossen
werden diese leute brauchen dann
plötzlich eigentlich eine art schutz
aber man kann halt nicht irgendwie zur
polizei gehen weil man ist ja
gangsta-rapper schönes leben machen
nach mir die sintflut alice im
wunderland
[Musik]